Profª. Tamar Gendler: Então, eu
quero falar na aula de hoje sobre
uma vertente da tradição
filosófica que não analisa
como a interconexão humana pode
proporcionar significado
e possibilidade de prosperidade,
mas que parece um pouco
com um determinado tipo de
distanciamento psicológico, como
forma
de lidar com as vicissitudes
inevitáveis ??da experiência vivida.
E a articulação mais clara das
perspectivas que vamos considerar hoje,
no contexto da tradição ocidental,
pode ser encontrada nos escritos
do filósofo Epicteto.
Aqui está um retrato maravilhoso
dele, imaginário, de 1715,
sentado à mesa com a bengala
que ele costumava usar,
já que era coxo.
Como vocês sabem, pelo guia de leitura,
Epicteto viveu no início de
2 milênios atrás.
Ele viveu cerca de 50 a 130 d.C.
Ele nasceu na Ásia Menor
de língua grega
e passou a sua vida no Império
Romano durante essa época.
A parte inicial da sua vida
foi como um escravo.
Não se sabe ao certo se foi
até a idade dos 13 anos
ou até os 27 anos, mas, de
qualquer maneira,
uma parcela significativa da vida
dele foi na escravidão.
Mas ele finalmente ganhou a
liberdade e, em algum momento,
antes ou depois de ganhar a
liberdade, estudou as obras
e a visão filosófica de uma
tradição conhecida como estoicismo.
E são 2 as obras produzidas em seu
nome que sobreviveram ao tempo.
A 1ª é uma grande
coleção de 4 volumes
das suas discussões sobre
uma série de temas:
metafísica (a forma como é o mundo),
epistemologia (como devemos
entender o mundo)
e também ética.
E além disso, conservou-se o
extraordinário livro que lemos hoje.
O pequeno ensaio de 45 epígrafes
conhecido como O Manual,
que foi, como no caso de Aristóteles,
registrado por um dos alunos de
Epicteto e preservado dessa forma.
O trabalho produzido por
Epicteto, O Manual,
tem sido muito influente ao
longo dos 2 mil anos
que tem sido parte da
tradição ocidental.
Em particular, o frontispício que eu usei
para mostrar uma foto de Epicteto
é tirado da biblioteca por
ninguém menos que John Adams,
o 2º presidente dos EUA,
que tinha este livro em sua
edição latina de 1715.
Esperem até passar o eclipse.
Outra coisa interessante,
historicamente,
é que o volume que estamos lendo é a
primeira tradução em inglês
feita por uma grande mulher das letras
do século 18, Elizabeth Carter.
Embora a tradução que estamos lendo
seja uma versão mais moderna.
Portanto, neste trabalho,
Epicteto assume
muitos dos princípios do
estoicismo clássico.
Fomos apresentados, até agora,
primeiro aos escritos de Platão,
que é um filósofo sistemático.
Ele tem opiniões sobre tudo
e o seu compromisso
é com um certo tipo de filosofia
racionalista, formalista, idealista.
E fomos apresentados às
obras de Aristóteles,
a partir de um dos seus
escritos, Ética a Nicômaco.
Mas além dessas duas tradições,
a tradição platônica e
a aristotélica,
o antigo mundo filosófico produziu
uma série de outras perspectivas
filosóficas sistemáticas...
perspectivas que tinham pontos de vista
sobre quase qualquer pergunta
que você pudesse fazer.
E entre elas está a visão
conhecida como estoicismo.
Os estóicos sustentavam,
em relação aos fatos metafísicos
subjacentes sobre a realidade,
que o próprio mundo é uma totalidade
física orgânica governada
por aquilo que eles chamavam de
logos, ou razão divina.
Há uma ordem para o mundo.
E que a responsabilidade dos seres
humanos, a partir dessa ordem,
é cultivar um tipo
particular de virtude.
A virtude na imagem
estóica está em agir
de acordo com o que a razão diz
que exige a natureza.
Ela vai junto com este grande
esquema de coisas,
e não tentando lutar contra o que
é prognosticado para você.
Portanto, não é de estranhar que
elementos da tradição estóica
tenham sido captados nas
tradições teístas subsequentes.
De certa forma, a visão
estóica de que o mundo
é uma entidade bem-ordenada
governada pela razão divina
está no cerne de muitas das
tradições religiosas
familiares para vocês.
Então, a questão é:
o que é exigido de você
prescritivamente?
O que você deve fazer se essas 2
coisas são a situação?
O que os estóicos sugerem é que você
precisa aceitar o seu destino,
que ele é a consequência do
poder e da bondade do logos,
ainda que as formas pelas quais
ele é bom para você
podem não estar disponíveis para
você ver e que, para isso,
seja preciso moderar os seus desejos,
evitar o excesso de emoção
e, assim, agir de acordo com a razão.
Portanto, o uso
contemporâneo do termo
estóico,
aquele que não expressa
sofrimento diante da dor,
enfatiza o 2º desses
aspectos prescritivos.
Mas é importante reconhecer que,
como com todos os filósofos
que estamos lendo,
isso é parte de uma visão de
mundo sistemática.
A ideia não é escolher um
pouco aqui e um pouco ali
e não nos preocupamos sobre
como eles vão juntos.
A ideia é ter uma ideia
sobre a natureza
fundamental da realidade, uma
visão sobre como sabemos isso
e, depois, perspectivas sobre o que
devemos fazer como consequência.
Epicteto, em O Manual, se
preocupa apenas
com uma pequena parte da
imagem estóica.
Ele está preocupado, fundamentalmente,
em escrever o 1º manual de autoajuda.
Ele está tentando dizer ao
cidadão do antigo mundo romano
por volta do ano 100 o que
fazer para prosperar.
E aqui está o que ele diz que
vocês precisam fazer.
Você precisa aprender a responder
adequadamente a experiência,
fazendo 3 coisas.
Você precisa mudar as suas
percepções de mundo
para você apreender as coisas
de tal modo que elas não o
influenciem negativamente.
Você precisa alterar os seus
desejos em relação ao mundo.
E você precisa estruturar a sua vida
de tal modo que permaneça no
caminho reto e estreito;
estruturar as suas relações sociais
de modo que elas o ajudarão a
manter os seus compromissos.
E no slide seguinte,
na tentativa de ajudá-los
na leitura do texto,
eu sugeri formas de colocar cada
uma das subpassages do livro
numa destas categorias.
Assim, por exemplo, quando Epicteto diz
que precisamos mudar a nossa
percepção de mundo,
existem 3 formas específicas que ele
acha que podemos fazer isso;
3 componentes para essa instrução.
A 1ª é que temos de
classificar corretamente
as coisas em 2 categorias: as coisas
sobre as quais temos controle
– e vamos falar mais sobre
isso daqui a pouco –
e as coisas sobre as quais
não temos controle.
Precisamos buscar diminuir
a nossa taxonomia.
Também temos de antecipar a forma
como o mundo tipicamente se desenrola.
Portanto, precisamos não só
saber o que cabe a nós
e o que não cabe a nós,
mas entre as coisas que
não cabem a nós,
temos de estruturar as
nossas expectativas
para estar emocionalmente preparados
para o que vai acontecer.
E, de novo, eu vou falar mais
sobre isso em alguns slides.
E precisamos reconhecer
– em alguns aspectos esta é
uma alínea da 1ª –
o papel que o julgamento e a escolha
desempenham para determinar
se as experiências nos afetam.
Portanto, essas são as 3 coisas que
Epicteto diz que precisamos fazer
no que diz respeito à
percepção e, de novo,
eu vou dar exemplos de cada
uma delas mais adiante.
Vamos passar para a 2ª coisa que
nós precisamos fazer.
Ele nos diz que precisamos
cultivar desejos adequados.
Precisamos ter nossos desejos
alinhados com o mundo
de tal maneira que não estamos sujeitos
repetidamente à frustração.
E a maneira de fazer isso é
invertendo a relação normal
entre o desejo e o mundo.
Normalmente, os desejos expressam uma
maneira que as coisas não são,
mas você gostaria que fossem.
Ontem, eu desejava intensamente que
não houvesse o 8º dia de neve
em 3 semanas para os meus filhos.
Mas o mundo se recusou a
cooperar com isso.
Se eu tivesse ajustado o
meu desejo ao mundo,
desejado que as coisas saíssem
exatamente como o logos previu,
então eu teria ficado contente com a
presença deles no meu escritório.
A 2ª coisa que Epicteto diz
que podemos fazer
na elaboração de estratégias para
cultivar desejos adequados
é utilizar essa capacidade
humana extraordinária
para assimilar as coisas de uma
categoria às coisas de outra.
Vocês se lembram quando eu mostrei a
tarefa de seleção de Wason,
aquela coisa engraçada que teve
um A e um F, um 4 e um 7,
e eu perguntei qual o cartão
que tinha de virar
para determinar se era verdade que
se há um A por um lado,
existe um 7 no outro...
Essa tarefa era difícil,
mas quando eu mostrei que era
estruturalmente idêntica a uma outra,
a tarefa de ser mostrado a 4
cartões que tinham idades
e bebidas alcoólicas ou
não-alcoólicas,
e eu perguntei que cartões
vocês precisavam virar
para verificar a verdade de se
alguém está bebendo uma cerveja,
então ela tem mais de 21 anos...
De repente, vocês foram capazes
de entender a dificuldade,
assimilando o problema a partir de algo
que vocês tinham afeição.
Epicteto destaca que temos uma série
de habilidades para o desapego.
Temos uma série de habilidades para o
distanciamento psicológico.
Temos uma série de
habilidades para dizer:
"Ah! Coisas acontecem,
isso não importa".
E o que ele sugere que façamos
e, de novo, eu vou dar um exemplo disso,
é aprender a assimilar as coisas
difíceis de se desapegar
e as coisas fáceis de se
desapegar, e, assim,
explorar essa capacidade que temos
para a compreensão metafórica.
Finalmente, nesta categoria,
Epicteto ressalta a importância
de se habituar à
inevitabilidade da perda.
Aqui está a má notícia
para todos vocês.
Você vai morrer.
Shelly Kagan tem um curso
inteiro sobre isso,
sobre chegar a um acordo com
este fato inevitável
sobre a existência humana.
Mas Epicteto sugere aceitar isso
profundamente, de um modo
que afete você não apenas ao ser
capaz de pronunciar as palavras:
"Eu vou morrer um dia",
mas realmente se habituando às suas
relações com as coisas.
De repente, as coisas que pareciam
incrivelmente importante...
são menos.
Finalmente, Epicteto
aponta a importância,
se você está agindo contra as
normas de sua cultura,
de perceber que você vai obter
um retorno social negativo.
Passagem após passagem, ele
descreve a importância
de resistir à pressão social.
Quando as pessoas dizem: "Você não
está buscando honra e glória!
Você deve ser um perdedor!"
Epicteto diz: "Deixe-os dizer isso
e não se preocupe com o que
eles dizem sobre você."
E como eu destaquei aqui,
há quase 15 passagens que
identificam esta estratégia.
Por último, Epicteto oferece
uma espécie de truque,
uma persona que ele quer
que você cultive.
Você deve ser um tipo silencioso:
as pessoas dizem coisas e você
calmamente não responde.
Portanto, a estratégia que
Epicteto apresenta
tem essas 3 partes principais.
E o que eu quero fazer na
próxima parte da aula
é fornecer alguns
exemplos específicos,
observando primeiro o texto de
Epicteto, citando-o diretamente,
e depois sugerindo algumas
analogias contemporâneas
para o que ele comenta.
Assim, o parágrafo de abertura
do manual de Epicteto
é uma das partes mais famosas
da escrita filosófica
na tradição ocidental dos
últimos 2 mil anos.
Ele começa assim:
"De todas as coisas existentes
algumas estão sob o nosso poder
e outras não.
Debaixo do nosso poder estão o
pensamento, o impulso,
a vontade de adquirir e a
vontade de evitar e,
numa palavra, tudo que resulta
das nossas ações.
As coisas que não estão sob
nosso poder incluem
o corpo, a propriedade,
a reputação, o cargo e, numa palavra,
tudo aquilo que não resulta
das nossas ações."
Ele continua, para apontar um erro
que você pode cometer.
"As coisas sob nosso poder são,
por natureza, livres,
não encontram obstáculos à sua
frente, não são por nada limitadas:
as coisas que não estão debaixo do
nosso poder são fracas, servis,
sujeitas a limitações,
dependentes de outros fatores.
Lembre-se, que se você imagina que
aquilo que é naturalmente escravo
está livre e aquilo que naturalmente
pertence a uma outra pessoa
é propriedade sua,
então você estará
prejudicado, você irá
lamentar
e ser colocado em (um estado
de) confusão…"
... e andar por aí culpando o mundo
por tudo o que está
acontecendo de errado com
você.
O erro de confundir aquilo sobre o
qual você tem controle
e sobre o qual você não tem
controle leva à frustração,
chateação, tristeza, culpabilidade.
Por outro lado,
manter essas categorias alinhadas
gera o prêmio grande: "Mas se
você pensa que somente aquilo que lhe
próprio é que lhe pertence
e aquilo que é próprio de outrem
realmente pertence aquele outrem,
ninguém jamais irá colocar
imposições ou limitações sobre
você.
Você não irá culpar a ninguém.
Não fará nada contra a sua
própria vontade.
Não terá nenhum inimigo, pois
nenhum mal pode alcançá-lo…"
Porque as únicas coisas sobre as quais
você procura ter o controle
são as coisas às quais você
realmente tem controle.
E, como consequência, ninguém
pode coagi-lo, porque você
está apenas preocupado com as
coisas que têm a ver com você.
Ninguém pode impedi-lo, porque
ninguém pode entrar
no caminho das coisas que
têm a ver com você.
Bom, qualquer um de vocês com
experiência com um amigo,
um parente ou um conhecido que faz parte
de uma das muitas versões
contemporâneas de Epicteto,
na forma de um programa de autoajuda,
sabe que no coração da tradição
contemporânea dos 12 passos
encontra-se uma versão deste
pensamento epictetiano,
articulada em forma de oração,
provavelmente pela primeira vez
por Reinhold Niebuhr.
É a oração da serenidade,
decorada com beija-flores e narcisos:
"Concedei-nos, Senhor a Serenidade
necessária para aceitar as coisas
que não podemos modificar
Coragem para modificar
aquelas que podemos
e Sabedoria para distinguir
umas das outras".
Se as glórias matutinas não
são o seu estilo,
você pode encontrá-la
decorada com um cão.
Ou um anjo. Ou uma criança.
Você pode encontrá-la numa tigela
ou, o mais impressionante,
tatuada no braço, na coxa, na lateral.
Então, claramente, há algo
na imagem de Epicteto
que fala com a mente contemporânea.
E fala com ela de uma forma que,
quando eu pesquisei imagens
no Google por "Oração da Serenidade",
eu encontrei milhares de
imagens como esta
em todos os idiomas imagináveis.
Então, essa ideia de que é
preciso distinguir
entre as coisas que podemos mudar e
as coisas que não podemos,
e que uma atitude de aceitação
é o que é apropriado para as
coisas que não podemos mudar,
ao passo que uma atitude de
esforço é o que é apropriado
para as coisas que podemos,
é uma lição oferecida por Epicteto
para a tradição ocidental.
2º exemplo.
Epicteto nos fala sobre a
importância da regulação
emocional
a partir de antecipar o que
vai ocorrer com você
num ambiente em particular.
Ele diz: vamos supor que você esteja
indo para os banhos públicos.
Quando você estiver prestes a tomar
algum tipo de ação, diz ele,
lembre-se do que se trata.
"Se você vai tomar banho,
coloque ante a sua mente o
que acontece no banho
– a água se despejando sobre
alguns, outros sendo atirados nela,
outros resmungando."
Se você estiver indo para o aeroporto,
lembre-se que você vai ter que
esperar numa longa fila.
Se você estiver preparado para o fato
de que vai estar sentado ali,
esperando pela sua passagem, você
pode ajustar as suas emoções.
Diga a você mesmo, eu
quero tomar um banho.
Eu quero ir para o aeroporto.
Eu quero andar pelo campus
nas calçadas geladas.
"Eu quero manter a minha vontade
em harmonia com a natureza."
Se você esperar que as
coisas sejam como são,
então você não se frustrará.
Eu quero andar pelo campus.
É um dia gelado.
Eu sei que ao caminhar pelo
campus num dia gelado,
eu terei de deslizar os pés,
em vez de levantá-los.
Aquilo que anteriormente era um
aborrecimento se torna
um fato sobre o mundo que não cabe
a mim e, consequentemente,
algo que não perturba o meu
sentimento de calma.
A 3ª coisa que Epicteto
sugere fazer é reconhecer
que o perturbador para nós não
são as coisas que acontecem,
mas sim os nossos julgamentos
sobre essas coisas.
E vocês se lembram quando
eu mostrei a imagem
da morte de Sócrates, no
Metropolitan Museum,
bebendo a cicuta, e disse que a
morte feita com nobreza,
registrada por um bom agente
–algo verdadeiro, tanto de Sócrates
quanto de um carpinteiro de Nazaré–,
pode servir como um marco para os
pensamentos das pessoas
sobre como lidar com a vida humana e
as suas inevitabilidades.
Então Epicteto diz: o que perturba as
pessoas não são as coisas,
mas os seus julgamentos
sobre essas coisas.
Por exemplo, "a morte – diz ele
– não é nada horrível.
Ou então Sócrates
a teria considerado como tal".
A única coisa horrível sobre
ela... segue Epicteto.
A única coisa horrível sobre ela
está no julgamento dos homens
de que ela é horrível.
Nada é prejudicial em si mesmo.
Depende de você deixar que
isso prejudique você.
Quando você ensina os seus
filhos a não se perturbarem
com as provocações dos colegas,
o que você salienta para eles
é que o que os colegas dizem sobre
eles não deve prejudicá-los,
ao menos que seja
emocionalmente inquietante.
Se você não deixar isso ferir
você, isso não vai ferir você.
E encontramos voz a isso
– aqui está Laurence Olivier
interpretando Hamlet –
na famosa cena de Rosencrantz e
Guildenstern em Hamlet,
que eu coloquei aqui porque eu
sei que há uma produção
de Hamlet na universidade...
Então, Hamlet está conversando
com os 2 emissários,
reclamando sobre que lugar podre é a
Dinamarca, e eles discordam.
Eles dizem que a Dinamarca
não parece uma prisão
e Hamlet rebate: "Bem, então
não é uma para vós,
pois não há nada quer bom ou mau,
mas o pensamento assim o faz."
Quando você anda ao redor do mundo,
as coisas têm forma e tamanhos.
Esta mesa é retangular.
Estas paredes são brancas.
A temperatura é tal e tal.
Esses são os fatos sobre o mundo.
As coisas do mundo não têm
valências fixadas a elas.
Não está fixada a um evento
que é bom ou ruim.
É a sua avaliação do evento
que dá a valência.
Esse é o 3º ponto epictetiano.
4º ponto.
Epicteto aponta que existem 2
maneiras de ter desejos.
Por um lado, é possível pedir ao mundo
para estar de acordo com
o que você quer
ou perguntar o que você quer para
se conformar com o mundo.
Epicteto favorece o 2º.
"Não questione se os eventos
deveriam acontecer tal como você
desejaria, mas deixe ser sua vontade
que os eventos devam acontecer
tal como eles ocorrem, e
você terá paz."
Aqui está uma maneira de obter
uma garantia de 100%
que você vai conseguir o que deseja.
Desejar o que você consegue.
Se você desejar o que você consegue,
você vai conseguir o que deseja.
A filosofia contemporânea tem uma
maneira de descrever isso.
E uma das formas de pensar sobre isso
– eles usam essa noção de chamam
de direção de ajuste –
é pensar sobre o que é uma
lista de compras.
Como eu tinha um pergaminho sobrando
daquele contrato que assinamos com o
diabo, há algumas semanas,
eu pensei que poderia usá-lo para
a minha lista de compras.
Então, aqui estou eu, ignorante de
Epicteto, e escrevo na minha lista
que gostaria de comprar
maçãs, brócolis e limões.
E vou até a loja e o
cumprimento do meu desejo
depende de ter maçãs,
brócolis e limões.
Você, iluminado por Epicteto, vai até a
loja, olha e vê o que está lá,
desenrola o seu pergaminho e
preenche a lista.
Maçãs, brócolis e limões.
Até agora não há nenhuma
diferença entre nós, embora
a sua estratégia seja moldar o seu
desejo para se ajustar ao mundo
e a minha seja tentar moldar o mundo
para se ajustar ao meu desejo.
Mas o que acontece quando
não há brócolis?
Eu tenho na minha lista:
maçãs, brócolis e limões.
Mas não há brócolis.
Estou exposta à frustração.
Você, por outro lado, adequa o
seu desejo ao mundo.
Você deseja o que você consegue.
Então você muda a sua lista de
compras e está tudo bem.
A ideia epictetiana aqui é que se
você moldar os seus desejos
ao modo como as coisas realmente são,
você nunca vai se frustrar.
4ª sugestão.
4ª? 5ª? Um de vocês deve
manter a contagem.
Próxima perspectiva.
Epicteto oferece esta analogia
extraordinária do parágrafo 7.
Ele diz: "Quando você está numa
viagem, e o seu navio está ancorado,
e você desembarca para
obter água fresca,
você poderá vir a colher uma concha
ou um objeto qualquer ao
longo do seu caminho,
mas você deve manter a sua
atenção fixa no navio
e ficar olhando na sua
direção constantemente,
para ver se o Timoneiro lhe chama;
e se ele o faz, você tem
de abandonar tudo,
ou acabar tendo de ser içado a bordo
com as pernas amarradas,
como um carneiro."
A ideia é, claro, dar uma volta,
apreciar as coisas no mundo,
mas não ficar atado a isso.
Quando ocorre uma grande prioridade,
mantenha as coisas em
ordem na sua mente.
Ele continua: "A mesma coisa
acontece com a vida".
Você sabe como é se relacionar
com conchas e tomates.
"A mesma coisa acontece com a vida."
Estou citando novamente.
"Se você tem uma esposa ou filho,
eles são como a concha ou o objeto,
eles estão seguindo os seus caminhos.
Apenas que, se o Timoneiro chamar,
corra de volta ao seu navio."
Tome as estratégias que você tem
disponível para lidar com coisas
cuja transitoriedade você
reconhece e adote as atitudes
em relação às coisas que a
transitoriedade é dolorosa para você.
"Quando um jarro se quebra", diz ele,
"você diz: isto é apenas
um jarro quebrado.
Quando o seu filho está perdido,
diga: isso é apenas uma
criança perdida."
Essa é a consequência
lógica da perspectiva
apresentada por Epicteto.
Parecia realmente boa quando era a
oração da serenidade.
Parecia muito boa no supermercado.
Parece bastante preocupante
quando é a esposa e o filho.
O que é que está acontecendo?
Eu deixo isso como uma interrogação...
E agora, para o 2º texto de hoje,
uma grande obra escrita no século 6,
por volta de 524, por alguém
cuja trajetória de vida foi quase
o inverso da de Epicteto.
Epicteto, vocês se
lembram, nasceu escravo
e tentou dar sentido à sua
experiência de sofrimento
quando se tornou livre.
Boécio, pelo contrário,
nasceu numa família nobre,
teve um enorme êxito político
nos seus primeiros anos,
teve 2 filhos, que se tornaram
figuras políticas bem-sucedidas.
E nos seus últimos anos, foi
preso por traição.
E porque A Consolação da Filosofia
foi uma das obras mais lidas e
reproduzidas da sua época
– respeitada durante séculos
e por muita gente –,
temos estupendos manuscritos
que nos contam a história.
Neste, por exemplo, vemos
Boécio ensinando às pessoas
e, depois, trancado na cadeia.
Na prisão, onde é torturado, sofrendo,
Boécio se consola envolvendo-se
numa conversa imaginária
com uma figura que ele
chama de Filosofia.
Então, aqui está a Filosofia, que
vem visitar Boécio na prisão.
E o que a Filosofia diz para ele
é, em muitos aspectos,
como o que comentava Epicteto...
Há, segundo ela, uma roda da fortuna.
Às vezes as coisas começam
mal e ficam melhor.
Às vezes as coisas
começam bem e ficam mal.
Mas haverá, inevitavelmente,
um círculo para o que vem até você
e o que é tirado de você.
E reconhecer que não há
nada a ser feito,
a não ser reconhecer que este
é o padrão da vida,
é algo extremamente
libertador para Boécio.
Reconhecer que mais além de ter coisas
está a possibilidade de perdê-las
permite a ele chegar a um acordo
com a experiência de ter perdido
tudo o que tinha anteriormente.
Na parte final da aula,
eu quero voltar a um tema que
discutimos anteriormente:
qual é a utilidade filosófica
existente nestas obras
em períodos de extrema dureza.
A minha esperança, afinal
vocês leram um ensaio dele,
é que mesmo que vocês não
reconheçam este senhor,
vocês adivinhem quem ele é.
Este é o almirante James Stockdale,
que foi, entre outras coisas,
preso ao lado de John McCain em Hanói
durante a Guerra do Vietnã
e que também foi
candidato a vice-presidente
competindo de forma independente...
eu sei, antes de vocês nascerem.
Portanto, James Stockdale, como ele
explica no seu livro de memórias
incrivelmente emocionante
que lemos para hoje,
estudou as obras da
tradição clássica.
Ele leu Epicteto.
Ele leu um monte de outros estóicos.
Ele leu a Ilíada. Ele leu a Odisseia.
E todas elas formaram parte do seu
repertório cognitivo e emocional
quando, no Vietnã,
aconteceu o seguinte:
"Em 9 de setembro de 1965..."
Eu estou citando do seu livro.
"... voei direto para uma
emboscada antiaérea,
ao nível dos topos das árvores, a 500
nós, em um pequeno avião A4
– paredes de cabine
afastadas menos de 3 pés –
que eu não conseguia mais controlar
depois que irrompeu em chamas.
Seus sistemas se apagaram.
Após a ejeção eu tinha
cerca de 30 segundos
para dizer minhas últimas
palavras em liberdade,
antes de cair na rua principal de
uma pequena aldeia à frente.
Desamparado, murmurei para mim mesmo:
'Cinco anos aqui, pelo menos.
Estou deixando o mundo da tecnologia
e entrando no mundo de Epicteto'."
"Prontas à mão", ele disse,
citando O Manual, "lembranças
do Enchirídion 'prontas à mão'
quando me ejetei do avião",
é a abertura do parágrafo seguinte.
"O entendimento de que o estóico [...]
sempre mantém arquivos
separados em sua mente para (A)
as coisas que 'lhe cabem'
e (B) coisas que 'não lhe cabem'.
Outra maneira de dizer
isso:", diz Stockdale,
as "coisas que 'estão sob seu poder'
e as que 'não estão sob seu poder'.
Ou ainda outro modo de dizer o mesmo.
Coisas que estão no âmbito
de 'sua vontade livre'
e as que estão além."
Todas as coisas nas quais você não
tem controle, que, no contexto
das torturas na prisão, são um
inúmeras, são externas a você.
E, diz Stockdale, isso vai
me condenar ao medo
e à ansiedade – se eu as cobiço.
Eu preciso abandonar o pensamento de
que as coisas vão mudar.
No entanto – e isso é crucial –,
tudo na categoria A depende de mim.
Do meu poder, da minha
vontade, e essas coisas
são o tema principal da minha
preocupação e envolvimento total.
Essas questões incluem "minhas
opiniões, minhas metas,
minhas aversões, minha aflição, minha
alegria, meu propósito moral
ou vontade, minha atitude
diante dos acontecimentos,
meu próprio bem, meu próprio
mal. Meu caráter interno",
diz Stockdale em circunstâncias que
são inimaginavelmente difíceis.
"Meu caráter e minha resposta para
essas coisas dependem de mim."
E ele continua, descrevendo a
experiência de tortura usando um tropo
que temos visto
repetidamente nos textos
lidos.
Ele diz: "Quando torturado e liberado da
tortura, o que nós contemplamos
foi que havíamos nos envolvido em
um certo tipo de traição
de nós mesmos e do que representava.
Foi lá que eu aprendi o dano estóico"
– ecos do dano moral que falamos
quando discutimos o trabalho
Jonathan Shay –
"um ombro quebrado, um osso nas
minhas costas quebrado,
uma perna quebrada duas vezes, foram
amendoim em comparação."
Epicteto: "Não busque qualquer dano
maior que este destruindo
a confiança, autorrespeito, o homem
bem-comportado dentro de você."
As situações extremas que forçam as
pessoas a descobrirem nelas
aspectos do que elas são capazes
que elas não querem ver
são as mais prejudiciais.
Quando Platão diz: não há
bem algum em ganhar ouro
vendendo ou escravizando sua filha... "
Por que então ganhar o ouro vendendo
ou escravizando a sua alma?"...
ele está expressando o
pensamento que vimos aqui.
Quando lemos, nas
discussões de Jonathan
Shay,
sobre a experiência de sentir que
alguém traiu o que representava...
isso é o que leva a um
sentimento de dano moral.
E quando os indivíduos de
Milgram se veem fazendo coisas
que achavam repugnante... eles
tremeram, sentiram calafrios
e um distúrbio na alma.
Aqui, mais uma vez, é uma
resposta ao desafio de Glauco.
Mas notem que, embora Stockdale
leve em conta a maior parte da
noção epictetiana,
ele rejeita a parte sobre o
tomate e a esposa.
Ou seja, ele rejeita em Epicteto a ideia
de que as relações sociais
não são importantes.
No parágrafo posterior ao
que eu acabei de ler,
ele escreve o seguinte:
"Quando as pessoas são liberadas
do confinamento solitário,
quando são colocadas de volta em um
bloco de célula regular,
dificilmente um americano
saiu dessa experiência
sem responder algo assim,
quando pela primeira vez sussurrou
para um companheiro de prisão.
"Você não quer falar comigo.
Eu sou um traidor."
"Mas – diz Stockdale, fazendo
esse tipo de introspeção
cuja importância Shay enfatizou na
leitura da semana passada –
porque estávamos igualmente frágeis,
parecia que todos nós
respondíamos algo assim:
"Ouça, amigo. Não há virgens aqui.
Você deve ter feito a mesma
declaração que eu fiz.
Sai dessa. Estamos todos juntos nisso.
Qual é o seu nome?
Conte-me sobre você."
Para ouvir o conclusivo, para
ouvir que você é aceito
e que existem outras pessoas à sua
volta que querem escutar
a sua experiência dolorosa, foi
para... e cito de novo...
"a maioria dos novos presos,
saindo de um impacto inicial e um frio,
uma guinada nas suas vidas".
Portanto, a questão levantada
pelo texto de Stockdale
é saber se é possível considerar
um pouco da noção epictetiana sem
assumi-la na sua totalidade.
É possível regular os nossos desejos
não esperando mais do mundo do
que é possível conseguir,
mas sem perder as
possibilidades mais
profundas
de relacionamento humano?
Eu não sei a resposta,
mas eu acho que vale a pena
pensar na pergunta.